Loll
Gebaited
So Leute
Auf gehts
Ich muss heute noch ein bisschen
Linux Krampel erledigen
Hier ist schon jemand
Da ist schon jemand da
Ich versuch mal
ob mein Chat funktioniert
Perfekt
Moin, Joker Gaming
xFatal
HUBi, 1996
That's No
Master Cell, jetzt wirds aber voll hier.
Ich hab gar kein
wirklich konkretes Ziel heute,
sondern einfach meine Linux VM
wieder schick machen, denn
ich werde gezwungen
ein neues Notebook zu verwenden.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, wenn ich schon gezwungen werde, ein neues Notebook zu
verwenden,
dann installiere ich mir mein Linux drauf neu
und ich meine, das haben wir letztens hier auf der VM gemacht, das heißt, ich werde das dann
genauso einrichten
wie hier meine
Linux VM für den Stream.
Und dann würde ich einfach mal gucken, was es so Neues gibt und das einfach wieder hübsch
machen
und dann kopiere ich mir meine Config-Files rüber
aufs Notebook und dann sieht das auch schick aus.
Soweit zumindest die Idee.
Also es gibt ein paar Sachen, die ich noch machen muss.
Also erst mal das Allerwichtigste, womit wir anfangen.
Ohne gehts quasi gar nicht in der heutigen Zeit und ich zeig euch mal was.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste, das ist das einzige, was ich mir schon überlegt hab,
was wir auf jeden Fall machen.
In der heutigen Zeit
ist es ja absolut,
muss man gewisse Ahnung haben von Linux für den Stream hier?
Eigentlich nicht.
Man sollte einen gewissen Hang dazu haben.
Aber wenn du was nicht verstehst, kannst du ja fragen.
So und was in der heutigen Zeit da gar nicht geht, also es ist ja absolut nicht mehr
zeitgemäß in 2K18,
wenn keine Emojis funktionieren.
Und auch viel schlimmer,
Emojis im Browser funktionieren nicht
und
Emojis im Terminal funktionieren nicht.
Ganz schrecklich.
Kommt heute noch was anderes als Programmieren?
Naja, wir haben schon halb neun. Ich werd jetzt eine Stunde
meine Linux VM bzw. mein Linux Notebook schicken machen
und dann
weiß ich nicht.
Oder, wobei, Stunde, vergessts Leute, Stunde. So was kann ich immer ewig basteln,
das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ja, Linux 3D in 2K17, lull.
Also wahrscheinlich wird heute nur ein bisschen,
das ist eigentlich wirklich Programmieren, wahrscheinlich
schwätzen wir heute noch ein bisschen und basteln ein bisschen an der Linux VM rum.
Und morgen,
Eaxx hat mich heute gefragt, ob ich nicht mal wieder Overwatch
mit ihm spielen will.
Weiß auch nicht, warum das ausgerechte Eaxx fragt. Der wollte letztens noch seinen
Blizzard Account löschen, dass er nie wieder Overwatch spielen kann.
Und
jetzt will er Overwatch spielen. Also wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich werden wir morgen mal ausprobieren, ob wir es wieder auf GR
schaffen.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wie das läuft.
Aber das, das wir, also
jetzt wieder ein paar Wochen nicht gespielt, da fühlst du dich wieder wie der letzte
Mensch in Overwatch und kriegst mehr nichts gebacken.
Aber ich bin froh, dass Mercy genervt wurde und
normalerweise,
ich hab's ja schon öfters gesagt, normalerweise bin ich ja nicht schadenfroh,
was sowas angeht und ich kann mich selten am Leid anderer Leute erfreuen, aber
wenn's um Mercy mains geht,
hab ich da überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit.
Ich hab die, ich hab die ganzen Holzwets genossen im Battle.net Forum.
Wirklich, ganz, war ganz großes Kino.
Und am besten war der Typ, der geschrieben hat, dass er Blizzard verklagen will.
Habt ihr das gelesen? Das war so ganz,
das ist so komplett von der Realität verabschieden im Hirn der Typ schon.
Ähm...
Ich versuch' den, ich versuch' den mal zu finden.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ja, der Typ, der Typ ist es!
Ach nee, jetzt hat einer auf Reddit gepostet.
Ja, Achtung, Achtung, ja, der Typ ist der Beste, der Typ hier.
Oh!
Nein!
Der Forumspost ist gelöscht!
Och nee...
Das ist ja doof.
Ich hab, ich hab auf Twitter...
Äh...
Ich hab auf...
Ja, ich hab'n Teil hier auf Twitter gepostet, guck mal.
Hat der Typ, was der Typ für ne Scheiße geschrieben hat.
Der hat sich erst mal übelst über den Mercy-Nerf aufgeregt.
Und irgendwann hat er sich dann so krass reingesteigert,
dass er dann irgendwann geschrieben hat hier, ähm...
Äh, wenn er gebannt wird,
dann wird er alle Blizzard-Games aninstallen und Klage einreichen und ein Refund für all sein Geld,
was er jemals für Blizzard-Games ausgegeben hat.
Und das alles nur weil Mercy genervt wurde.
Das ist der mal geiler Typ, ey.
So, ähm, wie gesagt, das Wichtigste, was wir als Allererstes machen müssen,
weil das geht im Jahr 2018 überhaupt noch nicht an,
dass Emojis nicht angezeigt werden.
Und vor allem, also nicht mal im Terminal,
also es ist ja nicht so, dass man im Terminal irgendwie Emojis brauchen würde,
aber sie schaden auch nicht.
Schon wieder JavaScript? Nee.
Heute kein JavaScript.
Ist der Titel nicht angepasst?
Heute machen wir mal, ja, heute machen wir heute die,
mache ich meine Linux-Installation ein bisschen schick,
dass ich dann auf mein Notebook kopieren kann, die neuen,
die Konfics, die ich jetzt zusammen bastle,
weil ich werde ja quasi gezwungen, ein neues Notebook zu verwenden.
Ich habe eigentlich keine Lust, ein neues Notebook zu verwenden,
aber wenn ich schon dabei bin, habe ich mir gedacht,
komm, jetzt lest du den Gramm mal neu
und pass das mal an die neuesten Gegebenheiten an und, ja,
guckst mal, was es so neues gibt.
Also, erst mal ganz wichtig, Emojis im Terminal.
Ich habe gelesen, dass sowohl Chrome, also Chrome kann schon eine Weile,
wenn man den passenden Font installiert hat,
aber genau im Terminal kann jetzt mittlerweile auch Emojis.
Wer zwingt mich, meine Freundin, nein, meine Arbeit zwingt mich,
ein neues Notebook zu verwenden?
Ich habe ein Notebook, das ist eigentlich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Also, es hat irgendwie, was hat denn das, in den Vierkern,
Interlinks-CPU und das ist super, es reicht absolut aus, ja.
Irgendwie fast 16 GB, aber es ist total easy,
es ist ein super Notebook, kannst du überhaupt nichts dazu sagen, ja.
Und das haben wir irgendwie vor zwei Jahren gekriegt.
Und jetzt ist unsere Meinung, jetzt müssen wir alle neue Notebooks verwenden,
weil die sind sogar, also die sind nicht wirklich besser,
aber die sind halt neu.
Und ich verstehe zwar den Sinn nicht so ganz,
aber ich dachte, wenn wir schon dabei sind,
dann kann ich den Gramm mal neu installieren.
Freunde in 2K18, LOL.
Grills in 2K18.
Ja, die Anna, ja, das,
habe ich ja breit gedreht schon in ein paar Videos.
Obwohl, das ist mittlerweile echt schon so lange, ja.
Leasing ausgelaufen, nee.
Die ich, ich muss, so, also.
Genau.
Chrome kann es mittlerweile unter Linux, Emoji ist überhaupt kein Ding,
wenn man den passenden Font installiert.
Und ich habe gelesen, genau, um Terminal kann es auch.
Deswegen installieren wir jetzt mal irgendeinen Emoji-Font.
Was gibt es denn da so?
Die Google Emojis, die Google Emojis gefallen mir aber nicht.
Ich finde die übelst hässlich.
Habe nur ich das Problem, dass ich die Google Emojis hässlich finde.
Wie findet ihr die Google Emojis?
Ich finde die übelst kacke.
Guck mal, wie das aussieht schon.
Nee.
Die Google Emojis ist krap.
Gucken wir mal, ich installiere den jetzt mal und ich gucke, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Sind das überhaupt die Android Emojis?
Sind das die gleichen?
Wo habe ich denn, also ich habe das Tablet jetzt nicht hier, aber sind das die Android
Emojis irgendwie?
Irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck, die Android Emojis sehen ein bisschen anders aus.
Nee, das sind doch die Android Emojis hier.
Oder?
Ja, das sind doch, das sind doch.
Nee, weil die sind übertrieben hässlich.
Da habe ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Wow.
Guck mal, hat er das jetzt installiert oder nicht?
Ja, hat er installiert.
Okay, dann machen wir mal zu und gucken mal, ob es sich jetzt hier im Terminal Emojiet
hat.
Ja, funktioniert.
Easy.
Oh, bin ich froh, dass die mittlerweile, dass sie das überall eingebaut haben.
So, und wenn ich jetzt hier die Seite refreshe, geht es wahrscheinlich, nee, wahrscheinlich
muss ich Chrome neu starten.
Bam.
Äh.
Dem Font scheinen ein paar Emojis zu fehlen, würde ich mal so sagen, das ist hier nicht
so, nicht so ganz vollständig irgendwie.
Lul.
Aber die sind eh hässlich, die gefallen mir überhaupt nicht.
Wir installieren jetzt, wir installieren jetzt einen anderen Font.
Was, was gibt, was gibt es denn eigentlich noch so, also den, den, den, der gefällt
mich.
Scheiß da weg.
Bam.
Wer braucht, wer braucht Emojis im Terminal?
Die Frage ist eher, wer braucht sie nicht?
Was, was gibt es denn noch für schöne Emoji-Fonts?
Öh.
What wäre das, was für dich?
Gameboy Keychain?
Was für ein Ding.
Und was gehts da?
Erklär mal, erklär mal, so grob.
So.
Wir suchen erstmal Emoji-Font, was gibt es denn da schönes?
Emoji, Emoji One ist hübsch.
Emoji One ist hübsch, der gefällt mir.
Der ist schick, was haben wir denn sonst noch so?
Twitter Emojis.
Die sind auch nicht schlecht, oder?
Die sehen doch auch ganz ok aus.
Ja, die Twitter Emojis sind auch ganz hübsch.
Die kann man sich auch geben, aber ich finde Emoji One ist der beste.
Ja komm, Emoji One sieht doch schick aus.
Nehm das von Apple, ich glaube den Apple Emoji-Font gibt es nicht.
Und natürlich, der Witz ist ja, der, aber das kopiere ich schon mal, was ist denn das?
Der Apple Emoji-Font wird wahrscheinlich unter Windows und Linux gar nicht funktionieren,
weil es natürlich mal wieder 3 oder ich glaube 4 verschiedene Standards, stimmt, Copy-Paste
geht ja noch nicht.
Muss ich mal gucken woran das liegt, woran das liegt.
Es gibt ja mal wieder 3 bis 4 verschiedene Standards, wie man Emojis abspeichern kann
in Fonts.
Warum auch immer es nicht nur einen gibt, keine Ahnung, aber es gibt 3 oder 4 verschiedene.
Es gibt von Adobe irgendwas, es gibt von Apple was, es gibt von, Moment, das gibt es wieder,
gibt es wieder zig verschiedene.
Ach scheiß drauf, ich installiere jetzt einfach Emoji One, gutes.
Das ist total hängen geblieben, also der eine Font funktioniert nicht von dem anderen
Betriebssystem, es ist total beknackt.
Nicht beknackt, ich weiß auch nicht warum die immer sich für alles so unterschiedliche
Sachen ausdenken lassen.
Ich meine da könnte man sich doch mal zusammensetzen und überlegen, ok wir müssen ja nicht alles
3 bis 4 mal jeder was anderes programmieren, wir können doch einfach uns auf irgendwas
einigen.
Aber ne, das geht nicht, so mal gucken wie es jetzt ausschaut.
Ich kann halt auch nicht so spielen, ich spiele alles kaputt.
Ha, ja die sehen doch viel schicker aus, die gefallen mir, der ist hübsch, der ist sehr
schick.
Neustarten, Chrome, jawoll, so muss das sein, so ist das doch sehr schick.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal warum Copy and Paste nicht geht, warum geht Copy und Paste nicht?
Äh, woan könnte denn das liegen, Copy und Paste, es ist, wir rebooten erstmal, rebooten
ist nicht verkehrt, vorher machen wir nochmal diese komischen Gaps hier kleiner, das nervt
mich.
Weil guckt ihr, wir verschenkt hier so viel Platz, das außen und dazwischen, in 5 ist
ok, hier außen, so ist es besser, sollen wir rebooten machen, rebooten ist gut.
Ähm, würdest du eigentlich öfters Minigames wie vor paar Wochen To the Moon machen?
Ähm, ja, das ist eh ne gute Sache, ich hab aktuell keine Ahnung was ich spielen soll,
und es gibt ja noch ein paar, so kleinere Sachen, so irgendwas was nur ein paar Stunden
funktioniert.
Warum hängt denn das jetzt eigentlich?
Linux, LOL, hallo, wie gut, wir machen jetzt einfach mal aus, und dann machen wir wieder
an.
Na gucken wir mal, hoffen wir mal dass es funktioniert, ja, funktioniert, warum auch
immer das eben nicht funktioniert hat, ich sparse das nicht.
Doki Doki Literal Club, nein, nein, nein, das hab ich keinen Bock drauf, außerdem
haben das ja schon alle, alle Let's Player irgendwie rauf und runter gespielt, ne, da
hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
So, mal gucken ob, ob Copy Paste jetzt funktioniert.
Nein, ähm, woran könnte denn das liegen, warum, warum geht kein Copy Paste, warum geht
kein Copy Paste, ähm, ich hab ne Idee, man musste diese, diese komische, diese komische
Library hier installieren, da haben wir das letzte Mal nur Version 2 installiert, hier
ist die Version 3, was gehts dann, bam, so, wie wärs mit A Tale of Two Brothers, das
hab ich mir mal gekauft auf, auf Steam, das hab ich noch nie gespielt, das hab ich mir
mal gekauft auf Steam vor ein paar Jahren, und ich glaube ich starte hier das falsche,
kann das sein?
Hab mal, ich muss ja die Musik lauter machen, es nervt mich, ich glaube ich muss hier nur
vor allem bei User starten, das klingt besser, so, und wisst ihr was jetzt kommt, Reboot,
lull, dann kann das sein, dass der irgendwie keinen Bock hat zu Rebooten, wenn OBS im Hintergrund
läuft, weil ich hab vorher ein paar mal das Ding hoch und runter gefahren, Swap kann
Ding, das hat einfach funktioniert, was sagst du jetzt zum Gameboy, ja ich Copy Paste das
gleich rein und wir gucken uns das zusammen an, vorausgesetzt, vorausgesetzt das Copy Pasten
geht jetzt, Portal, Portal kenn ich schon, ist aber schon ewig her, Portal ist ewig
her, so, mal gucken ob Copy Paste jetzt funktioniert, hey, Copy Paste geht, so, jetzt kann ich,
jetzt mal mal mal den Kickstarter hier auf, den der Halbcorn gepostet hat, so, was gibt
es denn da, The Keychain Gameboy is now a real crowd founded Gadget, was ist das, ich
meinte Musik leiser machen, ja, wie gesagt ich bin ziemlich kaputt, geht nicht so viel
konzentraten, was soll das denn sein, jawoll, was ist das jetzt, es ist Tetris drauf oder
nur ein Bild, das ist irgendwas selbstgebautes, gibt es da, gibt es da so ein Too Long, Didn't
Read oder sowas, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, ja was macht das jetzt, man kann Gameboy spielen,
Color spielen, Sega spielen, ja ok, das geht aber woanders auch noch, ja und, also was
macht man damit jetzt, kannst du das auf YouTube hochladen was du heute machst, ne, das auf
YouTube juckt das doch kein, ok, das ist ein Gameboy zum selbstbauen, ein Gameboy zum selbstbauen,
und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie in dem Fall Keychain, dass diese Keychain nichts
mit Bitcoins zu tun hat, sondern ein wirklicher Anhänger ist, also ich bräuchte es jetzt
irgendwie net, ja, ich habe schon genug sinnloses Zeug, also ich bräuchte es net, so jetzt,
zumindest ganz ganz wichtig, das ist das wichtigste was ich brauche, Emojis im Terminal, sonst
geht gar nichts, so und ich würde sagen wir updaten nochmal, oh die Musik, das ist ja
schlimm heute, ich muss glaube ich was anderes laufen lassen, mal neue Mirrors runterladen,
weil das geht ja die Hälfte wieder nicht, vor allem, es ist geil, dass meine Pakete
auf einer Uhr liegen, die babyname.tips heißt, warum nicht, ja, das habe ich gelesen mit
dem Smartclass von Intel, dass du da mit dem Laser dann die Sachen ins Auge geschossen
kriegst, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert, ok, also, also Emoji Support
haben wir, was kann ich, wir brauchen unbedingt, ganz wichtig, wir brauchen noch ein bisschen
Transparenz bei den Fenstern, das muss sein, das geht net ohne, ohne Transparente Fenster
ist da nichts drin, also ein bisschen Transparente Fenster, das ist nicht total übertrieben,
aber ein bisschen, das ist schon, weil sonst sieht es ja kacke aus, ne, habe ich mich
vertippt, ich habe mich vertippt, hast du mal gelötet, ja habe ich, sogar ein paar
Sachen hier im Haus habe ich zusammen gelötet, halt nur irgendwelche billig Kabel, so, jetzt,
ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen Transparenz für Fenster, wichtig, so, wow,
sogar fading, ai, ai, ai, ai, ah, guckt euch das an, naja, unglaublich, oh, ich muss
Musik ausmachen, ergibt es da nicht irgendwas anderes.
Das Jahr ist ja nervig, ey.
Okay, es faded.
So, jetzt...
Mal passen wir mal die Config mal ein bisschen an.
Und zwar...
...dass hab ich keine Ahnung was es macht.
Ich will...
...eigentlich sollte ich jetzt...
...durchsichtiges Fenster im Hintergrund haben, aber irgendwie...
...hab ich das nicht. Warum auch immer war es nicht.
Aber ich will doch kein durchsichtiges Fenster.
Inaktive Fenster will ich nicht durchsichtig haben, was ich haben will. Ich will das Ding irgendwie...
...ein bisschen gedimmt haben, dass es dunkler ist, wenn es im Hintergrund ist. Das reicht mir schon.
Faden will ich auch nicht, das geht mir auch auf den Keks.
Das reicht.
Genug fancy Optik.
Ich muss noch umstellen, dass der...
...OpenGL verwendet, um da krasse Effekte zu machen.
Das ist teilweise übelst hart, wenn ich Freitags, obwohl ich nur vier Tage die Woche arbeiten gehe noch...
...wenn ich Freitags heimkomme, ich bin sowas von im Arsch, das hatte ich früher an.
Ich weiß nicht genau, woran das liegt.
Aber ich bin dann einfach total kaputt.
Und ich kann dann auch weder großartig denken bei...
...sag mal...
...wird das jetzt?
Ja, ja, guck mal. Jetzt wird es gedimmt, das Fenster, wenn ich nicht drinnen bin.
Mega-Effekt-Doors am Start.
Aber das nimmt mir ein bisschen viel, guck mal, das ist ja viel zu rad.
Sag mal, 20 reicht.
Genug.
Ja, so ist das, das ist doch gut.
Dann sieht man, welches Fenster aktiv ist, weil es mal kurz so flasht.
Aber ansonsten ist es nicht zu nervig.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ja schon Transparenz brauchen.
Ganz wichtig, Transparenz bei der Titelleiste.
Ohne Transparenz in der Titelleiste geht nichts.
Was es gibt? Es gibt neue Pizza... Ach, es sind keine Pizza Emojis.
Dann hätte ich sie hier irgendwo einbauen können.
Jetzt können wir ja zumindest schon mal Emojis im Terminal verwenden.
Das heißt, jetzt müssen wir eigentlich auch mal mindestens Emojis hier oben in die Symbolleiste machen.
Und dass das Ganze noch ein bisschen fancieriger aussieht, muss die Symbolleiste...
...also nicht diese Taskbar für Arme hier oben, was ja keine Taskbar ist.
Die I3-Bar, genau. Die muss durchsichtig sein.
Ich hoffe, das geht.
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert.
How to make I3-WM-Status-Bar transparent.
RGB-Colors.
What?
Verarschen?
Ich meine, wir sind zwar Unterdienungsunterwegs, aber ich...
...irgendwelche ganz so krass kryptischen Sachen will ich jetzt auch nicht copypasten.
Hallo, Prane Daily.
I3-Bar has transparency.
Ach, so geht das.
Okay. Ja, easy. Das machen wir jetzt.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Dann sieht das bestimmt voll krass fancy aus.
Besser als das andere.
Hoffentlich funktioniert das überhaupt.
Ach, guckt mal, ich habe jetzt ja die Variable kopiert anstatt den...
...weil das sieht ganz schön beschissen aus jetzt.
Da ist doch einer zu viel, oder? Bin ich jetzt blöd?
Wie geht man hier eigentlich Background und so an?
Wie macht man das?
Doch, so funktioniert das schon mal nicht.
Das geht. Aber ich bin schon mal begeistert, dass das geht.
Hier.
Okay, weil man Fotos aufmacht irgendwo.
Vor allem von einem Reddit, wo Porn drin ist.
Wobei, das ist ein übelst gutes Sub-Reddit.
Wer sich ein bisschen für Linux interessiert und wissen will, wie die anderen Leute...
...so ihre Sachen eingerichtet haben, kann sich das hier angucken.
Gibt es viel Inspiration auf das.
Okay, hier schreibt doch der Typ was da ist.
One Solution blablabla.
Siehe hier, RGB Colors.
Wow.
Ah ja, okay, das muss man da reinschreiben. Alles klar, mache ich.
Das ist halt so typisches Linux-Gefrickel.
Weißt eigentlich nicht, was du machen musst.
Aber irgendwie findest du dann was und dann ist gut.
Wie geb ich denn jetzt die Farbe an?
Hat er bis jetzt nur Ubuntu, was ist das? Eine Art Linux? Ja.
Ja.
So Leute.
Kommt mal, der hat die auch transparent gekriegt. Ich will die auch transparent haben.
Das ist halt typisch Linux-Gefrickel. Erst mal drei Stunden suchen, wie das funktioniert.
Muss man einen Ausruf zeigen? Ah, man muss das Quoten. Okay, man muss das Quoten.
Okay, ich würde mal sagen, das ist ansatzweise transparent.
Das war nicht wirklich, aber es hat wieder eine normale Farbe.
Das funktioniert.
Das ist zu kurz, der Typ hat recht. Das müssen...
Ah, es ist transparent. Schön ist vor sich hin, Gefrickeler.
Ja gut, AMA 2 ist halt auch, Creeping, das AMA 2 ist halt auch gefrickelt pur.
Nein, den Dehydrated-Bot, der ist gebannt. Stopp. Den habe ich doch letztens gekickt, weil er mir auf den Kicks ging.
Oh, jetzt habe ich schon mal eine äußerst stylische E3-Bar.
RIP-Dehydrated-Bot. Das ist total, warum macht man Bots, die man einfach so in fremde Channels einladen kann und die dann herumspammen. Das ist doch beknackt.
So, und nun, auch noch ganz wichtig, nachdem wir jetzt ja schon Emojis haben, für den Browser und in der Konsole brauchen wir natürlich auch noch Emojis für die Workspaces.
Gibt es denn ein Emoji für Weltkarte oder sowas?
Globe. Globe showing Europe. Das ist gut. Das machen wir dann als Icon für meinen Desktop mit Browser drauf.
Sowas hier. Boah, das ist doch geil, weil man sogar schon Emojis im Terminal haben kann.
Da merkt man, man ist 2018 einfach angekommen.
Jetzt ist es gleich schon mal Pimplevel over 9000. Das geht jetzt einfach ab.
Welche grafische Oberfläche ist das? Das ist E3.
Was ist das hier? Der da ist das. Plus, dass der da halt in der Default Settings ziemlich kacke aussieht.
Standardmäßig sieht E3 irgendwie so aus. Was halt, naja, was ich gerade sonderlich hübsch ist. Da ist das hier schon ein bisschen schöner.
Also bei mir ist es klassischerweise so, auf dem ersten Desktop habe ich immer einen Browser und auf dem zweiten Desktop habe ich immer ein Terminal.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, gibt es denn ein Terminal Emoji? Ich vermute mal nicht.
Nein. Ähm, gibt es irgendwie eine, keine Ahnung, Screen Emoji oder sowas? Television, Cinema, ja das ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht. Screen. Aber Screen gibt es keine Icons für.
Kann man das so einrichten, dass immer wenn du Maus klickst, ein Hitmarker aus Modern Warfare 2 inklusive Sound erscheint? Bestimmt kann man das einrichten.
Man kann in einer Linie prinzipiell fast, fast, ja nicht alles, aber fast alles einrichten. Das wüsste ich mir mal überlegen.
Gibt es bestimmt. Es war doch klar, dass sowas gibt, ey. Add Sound to your keyboard presses. Gibt es aber, da gibt es nicht für die Maus.
How to make sound effect when I click, ja. Das ist natürlich klar, dass sich schon wieder irgendwelche Leute ausgedacht haben, ne?
Schön, dass es geil ist. Du musst einfach nur suchen und hast schon irgendwas. How to disable sound of mouse pointer, Moment.
Denn Maus pointer hat standardmäßig keinen Sound. Also anscheinend funktioniert das, aber ich will mir ja nicht selbst auf den Sack gehen.
Was nehme ich denn jetzt hier für das Terminal für ein Bild, dass es ein bisschen hübscher ist?
Ja, hier sowas da. Einfach ein Bildschirm, da ist es gut. Zwei, zack, bam. Und dann machen wir noch einen. Und zwar der dritte wird was für meinen Editor.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt was. Da gibt es doch bestimmt was wie Texts, Text Notebook oder Open Book. Memo ist gut, das wollen wir haben.
Memo. So und jetzt sieht das ganze schon gleich nochmal viel besser aus. Ja, sehr schick.
Ich finde das hat auch so dieses Farbschema irgendwie, sieht echt schick aus. Gibt es heute noch die Sharp oder Rust?
Rust? Wie kommst du auf Rust? Ich will mich ja nicht quälen. Ich habe die letzten zwei Tage schon wieder ein bisschen mit Rust rumgebastelt.
Das hat mich schon wieder genervt. Die Sprache ist einfach nervig. Übels nervig. Das sieht doch schon ganz nice aus.
Was ich noch gerne hätte ist, ich hätte noch gerne meine IP oben stehen. Alternativ könnte man hier auch noch Emojis rein machen. Aber wir müssen es jetzt ja nicht vertreiben mit dem Emojifizieren.
Rust gibt es heute nicht. Ja, ich habe die Antwort. Rust gibt es heute nicht. Ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich da was drin machen muss.
So, was brauchen wir jetzt noch schickes? Ich bräuchte noch einen Clipboard Manager, dass ich Copy Pasten kann.
Ja, Brain Delay, das ist ja alt. Das ist ja alt. Aber der ist gut. Irgendwie finde ich ihn lustig.
So, weil die Leute gefragt haben, ob wir irgendwas programmieren, ich glaube wir müssen jetzt etwas kleines scripten. Was ich gerade mache, ich richte das Linux für mein Notebook ein.
Ich glaube wir müssen jetzt etwas kleines scripten, nämlich, ich würde gerne, und zwar ich starte jetzt hier automatisch, wenn ich meine grafische Oberfläche starte. Auf dem ersten Workspace starte ich einen Chrome.
Auf dem zweiten Workspace will ich einen Terminal starten und ich zeige euch mal was passiert. Das Problem hatte ich nämlich schon mal, wenn ich das so mache.
Und auf dem dritten will ich Visual Studio Code starten. So, wenn ich das so mache, dann funktioniert das nicht, weil der nicht darauf wartet bis der Kram gestartet ist.
So, ich mach das jetzt mal. Gehen wir mal raus und starten neu und dann wird das alles auf einem Bildschirm aufploppen. Guck hier, das funktioniert nicht wirklich.
Funktioniert gar nicht. Nicht zu sagen überhaupt nicht. Du brauchst jetzt mit einer halben Stunde, bis du das irgendwie zurecht geschoben hast alles.
Ne, das ist Mist. Deswegen machen wir das so. Oh, habe ich es abgeschossen als es noch geöffnet war.
Manchmal geht mir der Wim auf den Sack. Deswegen machen wir das anders. Deswegen basteln wir ein kleines Skript, was die Dinger für uns startet.
Und zwar legen wir das mal in unser Heimatverzeichnis rein. Hometest Startup. Dann machen wir auch noch ein paar kleine Delays dazwischen.
Kann er nicht einfach den Scheiß jetzt mal löschen? Oh, bam.
Du willst das Image auf das Notebook ziehen? Ne, warum soll ich das Image auf das Notebook ziehen? Ich mein ich muss im Endeffekt mein Heimatverzeichnis auf das Notebook kopieren, dann ist alles da.
Ich muss ja nichts machen.
Außerdem ist die Vmware Kacke so viel ist das nicht. Das sind Open Vmware Tools. Also ich könnte theoretisch sogar ohne Probleme das Image drüber kopieren.
Aber ich installiere einfach einen Manjaro drauf und schiebe das Zeug in mein Heimatverzeichnis rein.
Im Prinzip muss ich drei, vier Sachen über den Paketmanager installieren. Ich schiebe mein Heimatverzeichnis rüber und es sieht dann eins zu eins so aus wie hier.
Das ist ja das Schöne an Linux. Das sind alles irgendwelche Text-Config-Dateien und in der Regel bist du eigentlich zu 99% eh in deinem Heimatverzeichnis unterwegs.
Deswegen ist das alles gar nicht so wild. Und das meiste kannst du ja auch auf irgendeinem x-beliebischen Linux-System verwenden.
Das hört sich deutsch an. Ja lustigerweise. Ich sage ja irgendwie alles auf Englisch. Aber Heimatverzeichnis habe ich mir irgendwie angewöhnt. Das sage ich auf Deutsch.
Also wir brauchen jetzt irgendwie so ein Miniskript und dieses ganze Start-up-Zeug können wir eigentlich vergessen.
Kann ich tippen. Vor allem wenn jetzt der Linux Pro sieht, dass ich hier oder der Wim Pro, dass ich hier mit Pfeiltasten navigiere, da ist er wahrscheinlich wieder kurz vorm Kollabieren.
Aber ich bin der Ansicht, wo wir gerade dabei sind, wo ich jetzt gerade beim Erzählen hier bin, über irgendwelche Leute, die sich darüber aufregen, dass man irgendwas nicht so bedient, wie sie das sagen.
Dann darf man nicht so viel drauf geben. Weil es gibt Leute, die sagen, man darf beispielsweise im Wim nicht mit den Pfeiltasten navigieren.
Also wenn ich jetzt quasi von Anfang, wenn ich jetzt hier ein paar Wörter nach links will, dann darf ich nicht so machen, sondern laut den Wim-Profis muss ich dann, keine Ahnung, W oder irgendwie, oder was ist Word Backwards, es ist W glaube ich, B, genau, B machen und dann CW für Change Word und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber eigentlich ist das scheißegal. Das kann jeder, also zumindest mein Ansicht der Dinge, das kann jeder so machen wie er will. Und die Begründung der Wim Pros oder sagen wir mal der Wim Anhänger ist ja, dass wenn man mit H, J, K, L navigiert, muss ich das mal überlegen ja, nicht mit den Pfeiltasten, sondern mit wahnsinnig intuitiven H nach links, L nach rechts, J nach unten.
Und K nach oben. What the fuck, ja. Die Begründung dafür, dass das das Beste ist von den Leuten ist ja immer, man hat dann seine Finger immer genau dort auf der Tastatur in der Mitte, wo man, dass man schön schreiben kann und alles erreichen kann.
Die Sache ist, das ist in der heutigen Zeit komplett irrelevant, weil du 90% der Zeit, wenn du irgendwas programmierst oder irgendwas machst, du bist ja nicht der krasse Hexor, der sowas hier macht zum Beispiel.
Wir simulieren das Ganze jetzt mal. Du bist ja nicht der krasse Hexor, der einfach die ganze Zeit da sitzt und irgendwie so Zeugs auskackt. Das macht ja keiner. Das machen nur die krassen Hexor in den Filmen. Die Hexor in den Filmen sitzen immer so da.
Ich bin gleich drin. Lull. Haha. So, das waren so die Filmhexor am Start. Und die tippen dann auch so Zeug, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. So, aber das macht man ja in echt nicht.
In echt ist es eigentlich eher so, man macht irgendwas, hier sowas als ich, irgendwie ganz tolle Schleife, blablabla. Und dann sitzt man da und überlegt erstmal kurz. Und in der Regel nimmt man dann die Hand an die Maus automatisch und geht in den Browser und guckt irgendwas nach.
Das heißt heutzutage, wenn du was machst, switchst du eh 90% zwischen deinem Texteditor und dem Browser hin und her. Und den Browser kannst du nur mit der Mausgeschalt bedienen. Das funktioniert sonst gar nicht.
Also ganze Wimpernatiker da kann man eigentlich komplett vergessen. Genau. Startup.sh. Das basteln wir jetzt mal schnell.
Ein Mini Shellscript, was man eigentlich schon gar nicht Shellscript nennen kann.
Und da starten wir jetzt unsere Programme. Da werden jetzt die Programme automatisch gestartet, nachdem man die grafische Oberfläche hochfährt.
Cheat. Warum sollte ich denn sowas machen? Meinst du ich weiß nicht was das macht oder wie?
Es weiß wahrscheinlich so ziemlich jeder was das macht, der nur ansatzweise was mit Linux bisher gemacht hat. Also so einfach kann man die Leute nicht verarschen. Und außerdem funktioniert das bei mir gar nicht, weil ich ein Alias auf RM habe.
Mein RM nehm ich nicht, sondern wirft alles erstmal in einen Ordner der irgendwie Punkt Trash heißt oder so.
Keine Ahnung wo der Ordner ist.
Deswegen passiert bei mir eh schon mal gar nichts, wenn ich da irgendwas ausverseht lösche. Ja so weit dazu.
Ja Flo. Aber Hexor in Film ist halt eh immer so ne Sache. Da kannst du nicht viel machen.
Also E3 Message. Also ich will auf dem ersten Workspace einen Clone starten auf dem zweiten Terminal auf dem dritten Node. Und dazwischen muss ich 2-3 Sekunden warten, dass er Zeit hat den Crempel zu starten.
Also sagen wir jetzt mal hier E3 Message. Workspace, muss ich den Kram jetzt mal Copy Pasten. Workspace, wie heißen hier meine Workspaces? So heißt der erste. Guck und auch zum Copy Pasten brauchst du ne Maus.
Es gibt einfach keine ordentliche Möglichkeit hier beispielsweise aus der Mitte von der Seite was raus zu Copy Pasten oder was zu markieren ohne die Maus zu verwenden.
Man muss sich gar nicht, eigentlich muss man sich der heutigen Zeit gar nicht, das ist total outdated, man muss sich überhaupt nicht mehr dran gewöhnen die Maus wenig zu verwenden. Das ist beknackt, man braucht die Maus eh. Das ist outdated, overrated, activated, debated, das braucht man nicht mehr.
Also wir wollen auf Workspace, auf Workspace 1 wollen wir Chromium starten. Danach machen wir so wie es eigentlich nicht gehört aber in dem Fall die einzige Variante ist wie man das machen kann.
Dann kommen wir in Sleep rein, danach starten wir auf Workspace, auf Workspace 2, whoa, what the fuck, was hat denn da alles kopiert.
Die Emojis funktionieren jetzt auch noch nicht so hundertprozentig irgendwie, sie sehen ein bisschen kaputt aus, aber wurscht. Auf Workspace 2 starten wir Chromium Terminal mit einem T-Max dabei.
Danach machen wir nochmal in Sleep und dann starten wir, ach jetzt gehts copy pasten, was mache ich denn da eigentlich. Und dann starten wir auf Workspace 3 mein Text Editor und gut ist.
Also ich meine man kann jetzt ja wenn man eine richtig krasse Wim-Hack so ist, dann macht man hier irgendwie sowas, aber das muss man ja nicht übertreiben.
So und das muss man hier weg machen und dann sagt es Exec, ein, out, fertig. So danach können wir noch unseren schönen Composite Manager starten, der dann Windows Transparenz und Gedöns macht, weil das läuft ja auch standardmäßig nicht.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal ob das ganze funktioniert, so wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Verenden wir mal Window Manager und starten die neu und jetzt sollte der Kram sich eigentlich von alleine starten.
Oder auch nicht. Ah ich weiß was ich vergessen habe, ich bin ja auch blöd. Fällt es euch auf Leute, was habe ich vergessen? So an die Lilux Scanner, was habe ich vergessen?
Ich sag jetzt hier in meiner i3-Config, führe dieses Skript hier aus. So was habe ich vergessen? Ja siehst du, Leute kennen sich aus.
Ein Num-Lok ist nicht an. So und jetzt sollte das ganze auch funktionieren. Probieren wir mal so ob das klappt. So prinzipiell. Ja. Ja.
Ok, so und jetzt muss das ganze natürlich nur funktionieren, wenn man neu startet. Oder beziehungsweise wenn man Window Manager abschießt.
Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal ob das jetzt klappt. Das ging ganz schön schnell. Ja. Klappt. So das funktioniert jetzt nach jedem Reboot.
Nach jedem Reboot habe ich meine Arbeitsumgebung komplett am Start, so wie ich es brauchen kann loslegen. Das ist schick. So und das gefällt mir.
Das wusste ich sogar als Nichtlinux User. Muss ja auch ein paar einfache Sachen geben. Easy Clap. So. Der Gelegenheit fällt mir gerade ein.
Ich muss hier eigentlich keine 3 Sekunden warten, weil das Gnome Terminal startet eigentlich nahezu instant.
So. Was ich jetzt noch brauche ist ein Clipboard Manager. Ohne Clipboard Manager komme ich dann aus.
Geht das nicht irgendwie anders, dass die im Background starten ohne den Sleep? Ja. Das Sleep ist tatsächlich nicht schön, aber mir fällt nichts anderes ein.
Weil dieses, das ist vom I3 so ein Programm, wo man eben quasi sagen kann, hey mach auf diesen Workspace, führe das und das aus. Und dieses Programm, egal ob das was es startet, fertig ist oder nicht, geht das raus.
Das heißt, ich habe keine Möglichkeit hier irgendwie festzustellen, dass das Programm hier ein bisschen länger braucht zum Starten.
Nee, in der I3-Config direkt hast du nämlich genau das gleiche Problem. Wenn du das hier in der I3-Config direkt einträgst, hintereinander, dann switcht der Workspace 1, startet Chromium, Workspace 2 startet das, Workspace 3 startet das.
Allerdings der Warte nicht bis das gestartet ist, was dazu führt, dass er alles 3 auf Workspace 3 startet.
Deswegen geht das nicht. Deswegen muss da ein Sleep dazwischen und mir fällt nichts anderes ein.
Also ich hätte sagen wir so, mir fällt schon was anderes ein, allerdings ist das alles übertrieben kompliziert im Vergleich zum Sleep.
Man könnte hier beispielsweise gucken, man könnte hier eine Schleife rein machen und gucken, ob Chromium läuft und sobald Chromium läuft, macht man weiter.
Irgendwie sowas könnte man machen.
Ich bin ja auch kein Fan von Sleeps. Sleeps an sich ist immer ein Hinweis dafür, dass man eigentlich keine Ahnung davon hat, was genau passiert und was man jetzt machen soll.
Also in der Regel ist es eigentlich keine gute Idee, da irgendwie ein Sleep hinzumachen, das stimmt.
Das eleganteste wäre natürlich, wenn dieses Programm hier so ein Minus Minus Weight oder sowas hätte, aber hat es nicht.
Deswegen funktioniert das nicht.
Und ja wie gesagt, mir würde hier auch was anderes einfallen, aber das wäre dann 10 Zeilen lang im Vergleich zu einem Sleep mit 3 Sekunden.
Und ich meine, da Chromium braucht halt auch eine Weile zum Starten.
Das ist schon ganz okay so, damit kann ich leben.
Gucken wir nochmal, ob das alles funktioniert jetzt, nachdem ich es angepasst habe.
Ups, ich habe mich vertippt.
Passwort 123456, hochkomplex.
Ja, das klappt. Ich finde das echt schick. Ich finde das echt sehr schick.
So und was ich auch cool finde, ist dieses Dimmen von dem Fenster, das heißt, da sieht man immer, was aktiviert ist.
Sieht doch schon recht stylisch aus, alles muss ich sagen.
So, ich brauche einen Clipboard-Manager, ganz wichtig.
Ich hatte die ganze Zeit immer das Teil, wobei ich das auf Dauer jetzt ein bisschen doof finde.
Da Max, schau mal hier, Assign Workspace.
Da geht es ohne das Sleep.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel, weil ich kenne den Eintrag aus dem E3 Handbuch.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das ohne Sleep funktioniert.
Ach so, ja doch, das funktioniert.
Das Problem dabei ist nur, dass es dann immer auf den Workspace kommt, aber das will ich ja gar nicht.
Also mal angenommen, ich würde jetzt sagen, ich verschiebe jedes Fenster oder jedes Programm mit diesem Namen hier immer automatisch auf Workspace 2.
Und wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, hey, ich will mein Terminal immer, also Gnome Terminal, immer auf Workspace 2 schieben,
dann könnte ich nie sagen, mach hier noch ein Terminal auf.
Dann würde ich hier ein Terminal aufmachen, das würde automatisch auf Workspace 2 geschoben.
Das ist doof.
Deswegen, das Problem hatte ich ja schon vor einer Weile gehabt.
Mir ist außerdem, es liebt nichts besseres eingefallen.
Das einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, was vielleicht hier irgendwie als Option geht.
Du kannst das Programm trotzdem noch manuell verschieben von dem Workspace, ohne dass...
Ich will es ja nicht von dem an...
Ich will ja nicht das Programm vom Workspace wegschieben.
Ich will auf einem anderen Workspace das Programm öffnen können.
Und das sehe ich jetzt so nicht, dass das hier funktioniert.
Das einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, wenn man dem hier noch irgendwie sagen könnte,
dass das nur für das Erste gilt oder so, aber das sehe ich jetzt nicht.
Oder aber, dass man irgendwie faked und da irgendwie den Fenstertitel noch matcht oder irgendwie sowas.
Also mir fällt nichts Gescheites ein.
Also wenn dir noch was Gescheites einfällt, dann mache ich die Sleeps weg.
Weil ich bin auch kein...
Was? Hanzo Scatter wird reworked? Ernsthaft?
Scatter. Simple Geometry.
Wie wird er dann reworked? Da kann man gar nicht mal...
Scatter. Scatter. Das sagt Hanzo so geil.
Scatter.
Und was wollen sie machen?
Ich weiß, dass man es nicht so schreibt.
Scatter ist nicht mal da.
Ja. Und was haben sie jetzt gemacht?
Be removed. What?
Ja. Mal gucken, was sie da machen.
Ich finde, Scatter ist auch eine bescheuerte Ability von Hanzo.
Also sowohl gameplaytechnisch als auch von der Geschichte her ist Scatter around eine beklagte Fähigkeit.
Laut Story ist Hanzo quasi so precision-mäßig.
Genau. Und erzählt ja auch immer, wie geil er aimen kann und sowas.
Und dann hat er so eine random Scatter-Fähigkeit, als könnte er eben nicht aimen.
Und gameplaytechnisch ist Scatter around natürlich auch doof.
Weil mal One-Shotted sich und mal nicht aufgeknackt.
So.
Ich würde gerne noch hier oben Emojis rein machen.
Irgendwie verleitet mich das gerade, hier oben auch noch Emojis reinzustecken.
Ich weiß nicht so genau warum.
Scatter.
Was sind eigentlich für dich die Vorteile der ZSH, dass du die Shell, die Fallshell vorziehst?
Also ursprünglich habe ich ZSH eigentlich genommen, weil es da ganz gute Erweiterungsplugin-Frameworks gibt.
Wo man das halt ohne großartig Aufwand schön anpassen kann.
Ich finde das Autovervollschönungssystem viel angenehmer als bei Bash.
Man kann bei der Bash bestimmt auch viele so ähnlich einstellen.
Find ich schicker.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch für Vorteile, die man so spontan einfallen?
Ja, die ganze Promptgeschichte ist einfacher. Es geht aber in Bash auch.
Also zum Beispiel so Gitpromts oder sowas. Aber das funktioniert in Bash auch.
Ist ein bisschen komplizierter, aber es funktioniert auch.
Was ist denn sonst noch so der große Vorteil, ganz ehrlich?
Kannst dir anzeigen lassen, mit was für einem Fehlercode die Programme rausgegangen sind.
Geht bestimmt in Bash auch.
Wenn ich jetzt Bash benutzen würde, würde es mir bestimmt auch fallen.
Pass mir auf den Keks geht.
Also die Bash-Autovervollständigung finde ich doof.
Okay, jetzt fallen wir noch ein paar Sachen ein.
Die Autovervollständigung in Bash finde ich nicht so schön.
Mit diesem Menü, wo man anfangen muss zu schreiben.
Und was natürlich auch cool ist, dass man sich die letzten Besucherverzeichnisse anzeigen lassen kann.
Dass man sowas schreiben kann, wie R, B, irgendwas. Und dann Autovervollständigt das zu Repos, Knoam, Base, 16, Terminal.
Du als Gitprofi, gibt es für Zshell so eine Baranzeige, welche Username, E-Mail gerade im Repo verwendet wird?
Meinst du... Gehen wir mal rein.
Du meinst also das, was hier beim Comment drin steht?
Das da?
Also quasi deine Git E-Mail-Settings. Git User E-Mail-Settings.
Also ich kenne keine Prompt-Plugin, der das standardmäßig macht.
Aber wir können ja mal gucken.
Preview, ging das nicht auch irgendwo?
Ist da irgendwas dabei, was du standardmäßig anzeigt?
Sieht nicht so aus. Also du kannst das ja auf jeden Fall selbst einfügen.
Also Flo96, das funktioniert. Das ist wirklich schön auch an ZSH, dass du so Abkürzungen machen kannst.
Und du kannst zum Beispiel Sternchen, wenn du sowas machst wie E-M Sternchen, da willst du ja vielleicht mal gucken, was du das Sternchen eigentlich machst.
Da kannst du Tab drücken und dann setzt du hier alles ein und sowas.
Es hat viele kleine Sachen, die sehr praktisch sind. Oder auch dieser Directory-Stack, wo du dann wieder zurückwechseln kannst.
Du warst jetzt eben in Repostream, bist dann woanders hingegangen, machst was und dann drückst du eins und bist wieder drinnen.
Es gibt so viele Kleinigkeiten, die einfach sehr praktisch sind.
So, und jetzt auch mal zurück zu dieser E-Mail-Geschichte.
Also du kannst es auf jeden Fall selbst einfügen. Das ist kein Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es standardmäßig einen Prompt gibt.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal, was man da machen kann.
Ist ja eh heute Pimp-Stream, da pimpen wir jetzt mal unseren Gitprompt.
Wie heißt die nochmal Flo, was meinst du?
So, was kann man hier einschalten, alles standardmäßig?
Nichts, sondern nicht viel.
Hält sich sehr in Grenzen.
Was, die Auto-Complete-Shell?
Das ist in ZSHS eingebaut.
Da musst du nichts zusätzlich installieren.
Man muss es natürlich nochmal ordentlich schreiben, dann klappt das auch.
Und dann drückst du Tab und dann geht das.
Also das ist alles in ZSHS eingebaut. Du brauchst halt eine Config, wo das aktiviert ist.
So, was können wir jetzt mit unserem Gitprompt mal anstellen?
Gucken wir mal, was da noch so standardmäßig eingebaut ist, was man da vielleicht machen könnte.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es geht, dass man sich die E-Mail-Adresse anzeigen lassen.
Okay, das ist alles, was er anzeigen kann, wie es aussieht.
Da ist nicht die E-Mail-Adresse dabei.
Aber das kann man mit Sicherheit selbst einbauen.
Das probieren wir doch jetzt mal aus.
Was gibt es denn jetzt alles hier für Modules?
Git.
JIT.
Git Log Contacts Format.
Gut, da gibt es jetzt nicht so viel, da gibt es irgendwelche Alias, die kein Mensch braucht.
Git ist geiler Shit.
Ja, so viele Alias braucht doch kein Mensch.
Wer soll sich das alles merken?
Ich habe 5-6 Alias bei mir auf der Arbeit definiert für Git.
Zum Beispiel ein Alias, den ich immer brauche, ist git st für Status als Abkürzung,
weil git status ziemlich das meist benutzte Kommando ist und git co für Checkout.
Das sind aber auch schon die einzigen, die man wirklich braucht.
Ok, also die E-Mail steht hier standardmäßig nicht drin.
Was man aber bestimmt von Hand eintragen kann.
Das müsste ich mir mal näher angucken, das kann man garantiert einbauen.
Hier schreiben sie ja auch irgendwie, wie man das erweitern kann.
Also das kann man auf jeden Fall selbst einbauen, dass er die E-Mail Adresse anzeigt.
Die E-Mail Adresse rauszukriegen sollte ja nicht allzu schwierig sein.
Ja, so kriegt man die E-Mail Adresse raus.
Jetzt muss man nur noch gucken, wie man den ganzen Mist eben in den Prompt rein kriegt.
Was macht das hier, wenn ich das da einfüge? Macht das irgendwas?
Gehen wir mal innen. Geh Drehpora rein.
Ok, da passiert standardmäßig erstmal nichts, wenn man da irgendwas ändert.
Scheint bei dir nicht zu funktionieren. Ja, du musst in deiner zsh-config schon noch einschalten dieses Autokomplete Zeugs und so.
Aber das kann die von Haus aus.
Hab auf der Arbeit ein Skript, was mir alle Remote-Repos automatisch auf den aktuellen Stand pullt.
Ja, kann man machen. Weil ich da immer vorsichtig bin mit Git-Pulls.
Je nachdem, wie das eingestellt ist. Also das Default-Verhalten hat sich da geändert in der letzten Version.
Früher war es so, wenn du Git-Pull gemacht hast, dann mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat er nur den aktuellen Stand gemacht.
Boah, Visual Studio Code hat sich aber viel getan in der Zwischenzeit.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist Git-Pull so eingestellt, dass er nur noch den Branch, oder Push ist zumindest so eingestellt,
dass er nur noch den Branch pusht, auf dem du auch drauf bist, wenn du einen Remote-Branch, einen Tracking-Branch gesetzt hast.
Aber früher war es so, dass Push alles gepusht hat, was du lokal hattest und einen Tracking-Branch gesetzt hast.
Deswegen versuche ich die Leute immer zu sagen, sie sollen es komplett ausschreiben.
Da kann man eigentlich nichts verkehrt machen, wenn man es ausschreibt. Dann passiert auch immer nur eine Sache.
Was ist das für eine komische Musik heute?
Also die Hilfe-Seite ist auch nicht sonderlich hilfreich gestiegen. Was ist die Uhrzeit? Nein, die Uhrzeit stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Also es müsste sich jetzt mal in Ruhe angucken, wie man das hier reinkriegt in seinen Git-Prompt.
Aber es wird nicht so schwierig sein, sich da die E-Mail-Adresse anzeigen zu lassen,
wenn man erst mal durchgestiegen hat, wo man jetzt genau diesen Prompt einstellen muss.
Und vor allem, ohne da in dem Source-Code herum zu editieren. Das wäre ein bisschen doof.
Dann ist es ja beim nächsten Mal weg.
Das macht halt nichts noch.
So, und dann muss man das hinten anhängen.
Was auch immer das Zeug dann da macht.
Ja, darüber kann man es setzen.
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen? Jetzt geht natürlich das Einsetzen nicht.
So, das können wir mal ausprobieren jetzt. So, wenn ich da jetzt hinten irgendwas anhänge.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Das muss ich mir mal in Ruhe angucken. Das dauert jetzt zu lange.
Wenn man die richtige Stelle gefunden hat, kann man die E-Mail-Adresse anhängen, dann sieht man es.
Ja, schreibt mir das mal auf Twitter, genau.
Oh, ich spiele so wieder krass im Arsch. Das ist schlimm. Ich meine, ich muss das Wochenende jetzt erst mal wieder ein paar Videos machen.
Weil ich habe das an Weihnachten gemerkt, wenn ich keine Videos mache. Also vor Weihnachten.
Wenn ich keine Videos mache, dann sagst du halt im Rating bei YouTube voll ab.
Aber jetzt, seitdem ich wieder ein paar mache, geht es eigentlich wieder ganz gut.
Und jetzt, wo ich seit ich wieder arbeiten gehe ein bisschen weniger mache, wird es auch schon wieder weniger.
Guck mal, wenn man sich das jetzt hier mal anguckt, Monthly-Statistik, ist das Statistik?
Sieht man die richtig? Ich habe jetzt ja quasi 2 Jahre oder 1,5 Jahre fast gar nichts gemacht.
Und jetzt habe ich schon angefangen und es geht instant hoch.
So und eigentlich müsste ich jetzt weitermachen.
Wo es gibt es denn hier? Hier gibt es ja eben so einen, ja, bei dem Abosseller oder auch kein Wunder, ja.
Guck, ich habe ja hier, also ab hier habe ich irgendwie vor 2 Jahren oder vor, keine Ahnung, vor, sagen wir mal, 2 Jahre sind es nicht wirklich.
Doch quasi mittlerweile, ach ne, das ist erstes, warte mal, ist das Ami-Datum? Nein, das ist doch, das ist Ami, also sprich, es ist nicht, es ist der 1.11. und nicht der 11.1. Ich bin verwirrt.
Sagen wir mal, 1,5 Jahre habe ich ja aufgehört regelmäßig Videos zu machen und das hast du direkt gemerkt, bäm, ich habe kaum was gemacht, ab und zu mal was hochgeladen, relativ wenig.
Guck mal, ich hatte jetzt, ich hatte ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich hier quasi aufgehört, sieht man ja hier, ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich aufgehört habe, habe ich keine Abos mehr gekriegt, nichts.
Und dementsprechend, nachdem wir immer noch die Accounts, die geschlossen werden, also ich habe nicht wirklich, das täuscht immer in der Statistik.
Du kriegst nicht wirklich, es ist nicht so, dass die Leute irgendwie wild deabonnieren, es ist so, dass du geschlossene Accounts abgezogen kriegst, also sprich Leute, die halt ihren Google Account geschlossen haben.
Das heißt, du hast immer permanent Deabos, immer und es ist gar nicht mal so, dass die Leute sagen würden, ich drücke jetzt auf Deabo, klar, das machen auch genug, ja, aber das meiste sind irgendwelche geschlossene Accounts, gekündigte Accounts oder sowas.
Und wenn du halt da nicht genug neue kriegst, dann hast du hier halt mal einfach eineinhalb Jahre Minus.
So und hier habe ich wieder angefangen, hier habe ich wieder angefangen im Dezember und dann geht gleich, geht gleich Views hoch, sobald du was machst, meine Views ist klar und dann auch gleich gibt es wieder ordentlich Abos.
Und jetzt habe ich wieder angefangen ein bisschen weniger zu machen, da sieht man schon, die täglichen Zahlen sind schon wieder runtergegangen, von teilweise 100 im Dezember am Tag, an manchen Tagen, bis jetzt halt wieder so auf, keine Ahnung, 20 Durchschnitt irgendwie.
Und es ist auch schon wieder runter von 1300 auf 809, also ich muss unbedingt was machen, es geht mir so auf den Kicks, dass ich, dass ich, ich habe echt, ich komme irgendwie zu nichts großartig, obwohl ich nur vier Tage die Woche arbeiten gehe.
Ich müsste jetzt eigentlich morgen und Sonntag, müsste ich ein paar Videos vorbereiten, ich müsste, eigentlich müsste ich, ich müsste eigentlich drei Videos die Woche machen, das ist, habe ich zumindest so den Eindruck, dass das am besten, am besten wirkt.
Allerdings drei Videos ist ganz schön viel, das habe ich, das habe ich im Dezember geschafft, wo ich den ganzen Tag Zeit hatte, einen Monat lang.
Weil man muss sich ja auch immer mal überlegen, was man für Themen bringt, es gibt halt Sachen, die sind interessanter für die Leute, das weiß ich auch vorher schon, als anderes, zum Beispiel, ich fand dieses Video hier extrem gut, also ich persönlich jetzt, das hier, ja gut jetzt sieht man nichts.
Das, wo wir hier zusammen über, über Mädels im E-Sport und so gelabert haben, das fand ich extrem gut, aber ich wusste von Anfang an schon, dass das kein Video wird, was ich jetzt 80k angucken oder 50k oder so.
Wenn jetzt nicht YouTube irgendwie auf die Idee kommt, das irgendwo zu, in die Empfehlungen rein zu hauen, also man weiß ja nie, ich meine, das Video, wo ich durch den Schnee im Garten gelaufen bin, hat 2,3 Millionen Aufrufe, das darf man nicht vergessen.
Aber das war mir klar. Das hier wusste ich auch, dass es am Anfang nicht viele Views kriegt, allerdings dann über die Suche einige kriegt, das hat halt auch gestimmt, das, ja, dachte ich mir auch so, das habe ich mir auch gedacht, dass es viele kriegt.
Und hier war ich mir fast sicher vor dem Hochladen, dass es relativ viele Abos gibt, weil das ein Thema ist, was viele interessiert und wo ich kaum was zu gesagt habe. Und hier ist Cheetah im Titel, deswegen hat es 46k, obwohl ich das Video eigentlich gerade hochladen wollte.
Bestes Video ist immer noch das aller Video. Ja, das war ja auch Kontrastprogramm gegenüber anderen Videos. Ansonsten sind die Aufrufe echt nicht übel. Kann man eigentlich nichts sagen.
Da ist halt immer ein paar Highlights drin, wenn es halt was ist, was sehr viele Leute interessiert. Und das hier hat für ein Technikvideo auch ziemlich viele Aufrufe, diese Meltdown-Geschichte.
Ich habe es ja früher selbst nicht vermutlich gehalten, wie viele ordentliche Thumbnails ausmachen. Ich mache den Kram mittlerweile selbst, weil alle Thumbnail-Designer einfach so was von unzuverlässig sind.
Das kannst du in Tonnen kloppen. Deswegen habe ich mir heute das selbst gemacht. Und da ist ja nichts großartiges dabei. Man sucht sich ein paar Bildchen raus, bastelt was zusammen und schreibt was Fettes drauf und fertig.
Ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass Thumbnails erstellen jetzt super kompliziert wäre. Wenn man eine Idee hat, was drauf soll, dann ist das überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich wollte demnächst mal mit dem Danny ein Video aufnehmen, aber dann wird er wieder Grund und Boden gehatet wahrscheinlich.
Wobei, das hätte er wahrscheinlich selbst nicht gedacht, dass er im Jahr 2018 ungefähr 40-mal so viele Aufrufe hat wie ich.
Oder 30-mal so viele Aufrufe und über Millionen Abos. Das hätte er sich am Anfang bestimmt auch nicht gedacht.
Ja, so kann es gehen. Wir haben uns letztes Jahr schon überlegt, dass wir wieder was aufnehmen wollen. Da müssen wir uns bloß was Gescheites einfallen.
Weil das wird halt auch bei mir auch ordentlich was bringen.
Jetzt geht es um den Danny. Er heißt ja nicht mal Bernard jetzt. Ich verstehe ja, dass einige Leute sich darüber aufregen, aber es gibt doch so viel Schlimmeres auf YouTube.
Und der Danny selbst, dem kann man wirklich nichts sagen.
Null, den gibt es noch. Den gibt es nicht noch. Den gibt es so viel wie noch nie. Er hat mittlerweile auf seinem Let's Play 1,2 Millionen Abos.
Den gab es noch nie so sehr wie jetzt.
Doch, der hat massiv mehr Klicks als ich. Guck dir das mal an.
Also jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf jedem Video, aber im Durchschnitt hat er pro Video 3-4 Mal so viel wie ich. Das ist krass. Das geht ab. Danny hat 15-20 Millionen im Monat. Der geht immer noch richtig ab.
Auf seinem COD-Channel macht er nichts mehr. Aber gegen den Danny kann man echt nichts sagen.
Es gibt Leute, über die kannst du dich auf YouTube aufregen. So diese ganze Beauty-Fraktion, wobei das noch nicht mal die Schlimmsten sind. Die Schlimmsten auf YouTube finde ich, vor allem kann man sogar mal sagen im internationalen Raum, es ist nicht nur in Deutschland, sind die Channels, die dir erzählen wollen, wie du schnell viel Kohle verdienen kannst.
Das ist so ein Schwachsinn, diese ganzen Channels. Vor allem ist das immer die gleiche Masche.
Nach dem Motto, ich habe es am letzten Mal auf Twitter geschrieben, zeige ein paar Hottegrills am Strand, deinen krassen Autofuhrpark, dein Haus mit Pool und dann erzählst du den Leuten im Video, das könnt ihr auch alles erreichen, wenn ihr es nur wollt und natürlich müsst ihr dazu meine Videos gucken und am besten meine Seminare besuchen.
Und dann erkläre ich euch, wie das jeder easy erreichen kann. Jeder wird ganz einfach, wenn er meinen Scheiß kauft, wird er Millionär.
Und die Leute glauben den Kram, dieser Trick ist so alt, das gab es wahrscheinlich schon vor tausend Jahren Leute, die sowas gemacht haben, aber das geht einfach, das zieht einfach.
Dann wird dann erzählt, ja so wird jeder erfolgreich, so macht jeder krasses Business und so. So nach dem Motto, werdet so wie ich, dann macht ihr krasses Business.
Was die Leute halt nicht verstehen ist, dass die Leute das krasse Business von den Channelbetreibern sind und dass ihnen die Channelbetreiber nicht das krasse Business beibringen, sondern dass sie einfach Mittel zum Zweck sind. Warum das so zieht, verstehe ich nicht.
Ja genau, genau cheat, sowas hier, verdiene 500 Euro pro Stunde mit diesem Video, oh mann.
Ja und ich meine, es gibt ja noch die übertriebene Sellout Variante, die dann erzählen, dass sie noch irgendwelche Persönlichkeitentwicklungskurse anbieten, dass du dann auch so geil werden kannst, wie sie und sowas.
Es zieht halt einfach, ja. Ich weiß, wenn man sich überlegt, es gibt ja heute, es gibt ja heute Coaches, mittlerweile für fast alles.
Du kannst dich coachen lassen zum Flirten, du kannst dich coachen lassen für Fitness, du kannst dich coachen lassen für Ernährung, du kannst dich coachen lassen für Business, du kannst dich für alles coachen lassen heutzutage mittlerweile.
Anstatt die Leute mal so ein bisschen auf sich selbst eingehen und sich selbst überlegen, hey, wer bin ich, beziehungsweise, auch wer will ich sein, lassen sie sich halt einreden nach dem Motto, es ist nur geil, wenn man so ist wie derjenige.
Ja, das ist halt, das ist so alt, dieses Gelaber, ja, das gibt es, wie gesagt, seit tausenden von Jahren wahrscheinlich schon, aber der Scheiß geht immer noch.
Oh, jetzt kriege ich Money, easy Money, so gehts Leute, so gehts, so habe ich den gekriegt, zeig mal her, ich habe die Seite gar nicht auf, ich sage schonmal Danke für die Donation von Just a month, TestRalfaZ, verwendet man das noch, ja, 3€ THX.
Aber da kann ich mich, ja, also es ist nicht schlecht, wenn man, also das Wort Coaching ist ja allgemein, das ist ja so total overused, jeder coacht in irgendwas.
Sag mal so, wenn du zu irgendeinem Thema, wo du dich für interessierst, jetzt was besuchst und ich dir das da erklären lasse und alles, ey, das ist ja nichts dabei, es ist ja auch vollkommen okay, wenn man, was ich halt wichtig finde ist, dass man selbst, dass man kriegt meine Antwort.
Und da ist es halt so, man kriegt eigentlich die Antwort darauf schon, bevor man gefragt hat bei diesen Channels, so nach dem Motto, weißt du, wisst ihr, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, geht zu einem von dem ihr denkt, dass der sich damit auskennt und fragt ihn, dann kriegt ihr eine Antwort, eventuell kostet die Antwort auch was, ja.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, aber diesen Channels ist es ja eher so, dass ihr eigentlich noch gar nicht gefragt habt und euch schonmal die Antwort präsentiert wird, so nach dem Motto, werde so geil wie ich, um so geil zu werden wie ich, kannst du mein Zeug kaufen oder musst du mein Zeug kaufen und dann hast du auch 20 Mädels, grasser Autos und Haus mit Pool und halt alles und machst krasses Business.
Klar gibt es Coaches zum Coaches lernen, es gibt alles.
Das war, haben wir gerade wieder den Ohrwurm vom Mega Upload Song, oh ne, das kann ich jetzt nicht anmachen, sonst kann ich ja auch wieder den ganzen Tag an nichts anderes als den Mega Upload Song denken.
Zu diesem Thema wollte ich eben mal was aufnehmen, also zu diesem ganzen, hier mache 500 Euro pro Stunde, obwohl du nichts kannst, Videos, da ist YouTube da richtig überschüttet irgendwie mit.
Skype in 2K18
Ja, naja, so viel zum Thema, so wirklich, wirklich weit mit unserem, das gibt es doch mehr, WTF, so wirklich weit mit unserem Linusgepippe sind wir nicht gekommen, aber ging es ja, und Mega Upload Song halb, 2 Euro, ne das kann ich jetzt nicht anmachen, das funktioniert nicht.
Ne, ne das geht nicht, dann muss ich den ganzen Tag heute Mega Upload Song singen, ne das kann ich nicht machen, ich kann jetzt gerne refunden wenn du willst, aber ich mache kein Mega Upload Song an.
Mega, nein nein nein.
So, ähm, so machen wir jetzt noch irgendwas?
Haben wir jetzt noch irgendwas?
Können wir jetzt noch machen?
Ein bisschen Hintergrundmusik wäre nicht schlecht, ich hatte vorhin Hintergrundmusik, aber die ging mir auf den Sack, die ist jetzt nur ziemlich leise.
Ne, die ist halt nur ziemlich leise. Ein MP3 Player in die Bar, ne, brauch ich nicht.
Hier der Mega Upload Song, ne, ne Leute, kein Mega Upload Song.
Weil, also es hat einen Grund warum ich keinen Musikplayer oben hin mache, weil ich Musik nicht über die VM höre und auf meinem Notebook auch keine Musik hör.
Also im Prinzip brauch ich keinen MP3 Player.
Komm Leute, ja, wenn ihr das wollt.
Wenn ihr das wollt.
Haha, der Mega Upload Song.
Das ist doch schrecklich.
Upload.
Das ist ja auch schon Geschichte.
Mega Upload.
Der Typ hatte keine Ahnung in welchen Video er da letztendlich auftaucht.
Die haben alle keine Ahnung gehabt.
Die haben alle überhaupt keine Ahnung um was es da geht.
Dieser Song, ey.
Nicht lauter.
Das ist er doch selbst, der da spricht, oder?
Wow.
Oh man, echt fein, so catchy ist das schon, ja.
Das wiederholt sich jetzt noch mal zwei Minuten.
So ein Gift da hinten dran.
Warum hat er eigentlich nur 56 Kabos?
Es hört nicht mehr auf, oder?
Es hört nicht mehr auf.
Warum hat er eigentlich nur 56 Kabos?
Ich dachte er hat mehr.
Mega?
Nochmal Mega.
Jawoll!
Das waren auch Zeiten.
Muss ich mal angucken, das ist auch schon sechs Jahre her.
Mega Upload.
Tja.
So sieht es aus.
Mega Upload.
Hat sich aus.
Mega Uploaded.
Und selbst, ich habe überhaupt sogar vergessen, wie die Adresse von diesem Ding war.
Wie war es dann?
Mega NZ oder so, ne?
Das neue, was ihm ja auch nicht mehr gehört.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wem das jetzt gehört, das hat er ja irgendwie verkauft.
Hat er eben gesagt, es ist wie ein Impressum?
Ne, gibt es nicht.
Ich würde mich auch wundern, wenn es so etwas gibt.
Ja, immer noch Neuseeland, okay.
Für wie viel, keine Ahnung.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Ne, gibt es keine Geschichte zu, jedoch.
Ne, steht nicht da.
Keine Ahnung.
Mega.
Ja Leute, wie gesagt, ich bin übrigens im Arsch.
OMEGA Upload Emote, das ist eine gute Idee.
So, kann man noch irgendwas machen?
Also bestimmt, aber fällt gerade nichts.
Aber es ist ja noch nichts großartig drin.
Ich meine, wir müssen noch mal uns eine ordentliche Wim-Config aus den Fingern saugen,
noch eine T-Max-Config aus den Fingern saugen.
Wobei ich da halt auch vieles kopiere aus meiner jetzigen...
Naja, ich muss unbedingt noch mal History-Limit setzen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Wie geht denn das?
Das muss höher, History-Limit.
History-Size, genau.
Das brauchen wir.
Das brauchen wir, sonst ist da viel zu wenig drin.
Hast du schon eigentlich Suppe-Emotes für den Fall, dass du Partner bist?
Ne.
Ich hab noch nicht mal gefragt bei Twitch bisher.
Ich hab noch gar nichts und ich hab jetzt auch...
noch irgendwie keine großen Sachen vor.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich die überhaupt kontaktieren will.
Hast du deine Configs an, Brepo?
Ne, noch nicht.
Wie gesagt, die VM ist ziemlich neu.
Paar Settings haben wir angepasst, heute ein bisschen hübscher gemacht,
noch ein paar Emojis rein, weil es geht, nicht weil es irgendwie sinnvoll ist, aber...
Weil Emojis in Terminal und Browser, 2018 geht es halt nicht mehr ohne Emojis.
YouTube-Download schon installiert?
Ne.
Aber es ist echt ein sehr gutes Tool, YouTube-Download.
Was spricht denn gegen Partnern, dass ich dann noch mehr das Gefühl hab,
ich müsste was machen?
Ich mein, ich kann nicht wirklich für so Streams wie heute da irgendwie Kohle nehmen indirekt.
Ich mein, ich hab den Stream heute Abend angemacht,
um ein bisschen an meiner Linux-Vereinbarung zu basteln und ich bin übelst im Arsch.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt hier irgendetwas sonderlich Gescheites bei rumkommen würde oder so.
Ich mache im Endeffekt nichts und gucke ab und zu mal in den Chat und sache ein bisschen was.
Das ist unser Stream heute Abend zusammengefasst ganz gut.
Kann ja jeder selbst entscheiden, ja kann jeder selbst entscheiden, aber ich mein,
es ist trotzdem Unterschied, ob du halt dann drauf guckst und siehst,
du hast irgendwie ein paar Abonnenten, die halt Geld für irgendwas bezahlen.
Du steams dann zwei oder drei Wochen nicht und dann machst du nur mal einen Stream,
der halt einfach nur kurz ist oder halt nicht das ist, als dich die Leute abonniert haben.
Das ist halt das Problem dabei.
Da fühlst du dich instant zu Sachen verpflichtet, sobald du Abos hast.
Der Stream zusammengefasst mega.
Das machen wir, wir machen das noch mal hier. Linux 3D.
Das ist so schlecht. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das immer noch standardmäßig dabei ist.
Könnte man da nicht mal ein bisschen was hübscheres machen als so abgrundtief hässliche Zahnräder,
die sich damit relativ viel FPS drehen, aber trotzdem ruckeln.
Da noch lieber sowas.
Aber es gibt noch mehr, es gibt noch mehr.
Das 3D-Demo, das ist so unglaublich schlecht.
Das ist so schlecht. Guckt euch die Bäume an.
Gut, ich meine, das sind eigentlich nur irgendwelche Testdinger,
ob wahrscheinlich die Grafikdräger richtig funktionieren,
aber es sieht halt einfach lächerlich schlecht aus.
Ist das nur bei Arch Linux? Nee, das ist überall dabei.
Galaxy ist überall dabei.
Das sieht halt wirklich schlecht geblieben aus.
Und dann belegt es auch noch so ein Kommando wie Fire,
was man super für praktischere Sachen verwenden könnte.
Also das heißt belegt, heißt halt auch so.
Woher ist die T-Markt-Conf?
Die habe ich mir.
Also wir haben noch nicht viel angepasst.
Eigentlich haben wir gar nichts angepasst letzten Stream.
Die habe ich mir irgendwoher kopiert,
weil ich nicht den zweiten Rechner anschalten wollte, um eine runterzuziehen.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, woher ich mir die her kopiert habe.
Ich meine, wenn man mal danach sucht, wird man die wahrscheinlich sogar finden.
Die habe ich mir irgendwoher kopiert.
Ja, wahrscheinlich die hier, vermute ich jetzt mal.
Okay, die ist nicht.
Sieht aber fast nach der aus.
Nee, das ist die nicht.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo ich die her kopiert habe.
Aber ich lade das, wenn ihr wollt.
Ich kann meinen ganzen Config-Rahmen, wenn ich hier mal fertig mit dem Einrichten bin,
wenn es dann in dem Zustand ist, wo ich es dann auch für das Notebook verwende,
kann ich den ganzen Krempel mal hochladen auf GitHub.
Wie gesagt, in der Wimac ist auch nichts drin.
Ich setze die Suche in Anführungsstrichen.
Ja, da ist sie doch.
Die habe ich mir kopiert.
Die habe ich mir hauptsächlich kopiert.
Ich meine, da ist ja nichts Großartiges drin.
Die habe ich mir eigentlich nur wegen dem Farbschema hier unten kopiert,
weil die Leiste gescheit aussieht.
Das ist alles.
Aber wie gesagt, da ist nichts drin, auch keine Shortcuts und so.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich meine andere T-Mox-Config schnell mal von der VM runterziehen kann.
Wie gesagt, hier sind überhaupt keine Shortcuts dabei.
Zum Beispiel, was mir überhaupt nicht gefällt, ist, wenn ich zum Fensterwechseln
oder zum Panelswechseln quasi erst den T-Mox Escape drücken muss und dann File-Taste.
Ich finde es viel besser, wenn ich einfach direkt Shift und File-Taste drücken kann.
Das machen wir jetzt noch. Das nervt mich hier auch.
Ich kopiere mir jetzt mal ein paar Sachen aus meiner anderen T-Mox-Config rüber.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich die VM ankriege.
So, kopieren wir mal.
Meine alte T-Mox-Config, die ist so unaufgeräumt. Du findest ja gar nichts.
Okay, also was ich auf jeden Fall brauche, ist das hier.
Auch mal den Kram unten. Was ich auf jeden Fall brauche, ist den Shortcut für CTRL-F,
dass ich das aktuelle Fenster auf Vollbild mache.
Wie kann man das eigentlich so neu einlesen, irgendwie die Config?
Ja, funktioniert, genau. Auf CTRL-F brauche ich immer, dass ich Fenster maximieren kann.
Das untere rechte Fenster mache ich jetzt auf Vollbild. Oder halt Panel in T-Mox.
Das brauche ich immer. Ohne kann ich nicht arbeiten, das funktioniert nicht.
So, und dann brauchen wir auch noch Bind. Wo habe ich es denn?
Ich habe eigentlich auch noch irgendwo... Ah ja, jetzt war meine Config unübersichtlich.
Ja, den brauche ich auch noch. CTRL-Left geht dann auf Select-PL.
Kopiere mal den Kram gerade mal. Jetzt kann ich ein bisschen Win-Magic machen. FL, Change Word, Down, Up, Right.
Da kann ich jetzt nämlich mit CTRL-File-Tasten navigieren, was einfach viel praktischer ist als sonst.
Jetzt kann ich hier dazwischen wechseln, ohne dass ich immer diese Escape-Taste drücken muss, was einfach zackt einfach nur.
Warum braucht man T-Mox in E3? Weil ich mich daran gewöhnt habe.
Und weil natürlich mit T-Mox noch andere Vorteile hast. Du kannst zum Beispiel detachen, das Terminal zu machen.
Und wenn du das Terminal jetzt wieder aufmachst, dann ist noch alles da.
Was natürlich super ist, wenn du etwas im Hintergrund laufen lassen willst.
Du hast einen eigenen Scroll-Back-Buffer.
Einen Scroll-Back-Buffer, den du durchsuchen kannst.
Den hast du. Ups. Ich weiß. Moment.
Ah, ich habe keine WI-Keybindings.
Also normalerweise, wenn man jetzt die Taste wüsste, könnte man dann auch suchen hier in dem Scroll-Back-Buffer.
Aber ich habe die Tastenkombination nicht aktiviert.
Ich weiß nicht, was man dafür drücken muss.
Ich finde die Handhabung gleich praktisch mit den unterschiedlichen Tabs.
Wobei du das natürlich auch über Desktops und einzelne Terminals abbilden könntest.
Also ich habe mich mittlerweile so dran gewöhnt, ich kann einst immer ohne Arbeiten zu funktionieren.
So Leute. 22 oder 22?
Wie gesagt, ich bin eh schon den ganzen Tag, jetzt seit ich hier am Rechner bin, voll.
Was? Dein Notebook wird dualboot oder linux-only? Es wird linux-only.
Das ist ja ein Notebook, auf dem ich arbeiten will. Da muss kein Windows drauf.
Wenn du es dann über Desktop auf eine VM, um die ich mich nicht selbst kümmere,
da kommt einfach nur linux drauf auf das Notebook. Sonst nichts.
Welches Notebook hast du? Was ist das? Ein Lenovo?
Ich habe es gerade nicht hier, ich kann nicht drauf gucken.
Wie gesagt, das steht auf der Arbeit. Aber ich werde dazu gezwungen, das neue Notebook zu verwenden.
Irgendein Lenovo Notebook ist das.
Mit Trackball, ich glaube das hat kein Trackball mehr. Oder hat es?
Könnte sein, ich habe das eh immer zu. Ich habe immer eine Tastatur dran.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es einen Nippel hat. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht.
Ich kann jetzt nicht nachgucken. Also die Lenovo Dinge haben ja öfters mal einen Nippel.
Aber ich habe auf der Arbeit einen 27 Zoll Curved.
Also das Monitor ist gefühlt riesig. Ich habe ein Notebook dran und eine Tastatur.
Und meine Logitech G502. Ich bin der Einzige, der mit so einer super fancy Maus rumrennt.
War die das? Ja, genau. Ich verwende sie mittlerweile auf der Arbeit.
Dafür ist sie echt gut. Zum Spielen ist sie mir zu schwer.
Es ist kein 27 Zoll Notebook. Es ist ein 27 Zoll Curved Bildschirm, der angeschlossen ist.
Deswegen habe ich das Notebook auch nie auf und weiß jetzt nicht, ob es einen Nippel hat oder nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Warum bekommt ihr so fancy Arbeitsequipment? Das ist doch gar nicht so fancy.
Da braucht man auch irgendwas, mit dem man ordentlich arbeiten kann.
Du kannst ja nicht den Leuten immer den letzten... Ich weiß, das machen viele Firmen.
Aber es geht halt nach hinten los. Du kannst ja deinen Leuten nicht den letzten Crap hinstellen.
Und dann irgendwie erwarten, dass es funktioniert.
Aber ich werde sie einspannen.
Ich finde das sieht echt ganz hübsch aus.
Eine Sache, die wir jetzt noch machen, ist, wir stellen die Schrift noch eins drauf.
Ja, das ist die optimale Schriftgröße für mich.
Die Leute stehen total auf Minischrift.
Wir haben genug Leute, die haben so etwas am Start.
Da arbeiten sie den ganzen Tag mit.
Da fallen mir die Augen aus.
Kannst du mir erklären, was es mit einem Nippel beim Notebook auf sich hat?
Das zeige ich dir mal auf Google.
Da muss man bloß jetzt aufpassen, was mal eintippt.
Sonst gleich banned.
Das da.
Das ist der Nippel.
Hier sieht man es ganz gut auf einer Tastatur.
Das ist so ein Mini-Joystick.
Immer noch nicht die Zeit gefixt, stimmt.
Warum ist die Zeit eigentlich so kacke?
Aha, die Zeit ist richtig.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Da bin ich raus.
Habe ich eine Weile verwendet, vor ein paar Jahren.
Ich war ja lange Jahre Wim-only Benutzer.
Mit 30 Plugins drin.
Mit allem möglichen Scheiß.
Wim ist nicht so gut gealtert.
Wim ist schon ganz schön alt und funktioniert ja prinzipiell.
Aber du merkst, umso mehr Sachen du versuchst einzubauen,
umso weniger rund läuft das Ganze und umso weniger läuft das miteinander gut zusammen.
Aber wenn du eine Wim hast mit 30 Plugins drin,
das reiche ich auch schon 10, wenn es die richtigen sind,
da ist er erstens ein bisschen langsamer, das ist nicht so wild.
Und die Plugins haben oftmals auch Probleme miteinander.
Deswegen bin ich wieder zurückgegangen auf minimal Wim-Config
und verwende jetzt relativ häufig tatsächlich Visual Studio Code für irgendwelche Sachen.
Aber ich denke, man sollte einfach das verwenden, was für die jeweilige Sprache
und was man machen will am besten ist.
EMAX, EMAX bin ich nie großartig mit warm geworden.
Ich habe es ein paar Mal ausprobiert.
Auch mit ein paar Plugins, wo du dann irgendwelche Wim-Shortcuts hast und sowas.
Aber EMAX bin ich nicht warm geworden.
Das Schöne an Wim ist auch, wenn man da ein bisschen was mit kann,
du kannst es halt auf jedem Server der Welt verwenden.
Es ist halt immer drauf, was bei EMAX nicht so ist.
Und außerdem ist das Terminal bei EMAX scheiße.
Im EMAX ist das mittlerweile ganz gut, bei dem aktuellen, also das eingebaute Terminal.
Wenn man sowas hier machen will wie in Visual Studio,
dass man hier oben Editor hat und unten Terminal.
Das geht in EMAX nicht gescheit.
Da gibt es zwar welche, aber die sind kacke.
Ja, JavaScript macht tatsächlich auf keinem Editor so richtig Spaß, das stimmt.
Das liegt aber vor allem daran, dass...
Habe ich das noch in der Historie?
Das liegt vor allem an den tollen Eigenschaften von JavaScript.
Ich meine, wir würden auch erwarten, dass not a number equal not a number ist.
Das kann nicht sein.
Oder das pass in fuck not a number.
Das kann immer noch... Egal, fangen wir nicht wieder davon an.
Text-Editing mit Echo-Cad-Crap und Redirects.
Ja, mit Add, wenn schon. Nee, kann nicht mehr drauf.
Mit Seed, mit Seed.
Die richtig coolen Leute brauchen keinen interaktiven Editor.
Die editieren das mit Seed.
Also die richtig krassen Hexor, wenn die irgendwie eine Text-Datei haben,
in der jetzt drinne steht, keine Ahnung,
Stream 0 und die wollen 0 durch Woodface ersetzen,
dann machen das die richtig krassen Hexor nicht etwa so,
dass die den Editor aufmachen und dann hier reinschreiben Woodface,
sondern die machen was anderes.
Sie sagen dann Seed, 0 durch Woodface, Plop.
So machen die das.
Da machen sie noch ein Minus i.
Wenn man dann in die Datei wieder reinguckt,
dann ist dann 0 weg.
So machen das die richtig mega krassen Hexor.
Wie findest du die Overwatch League bis jetzt?
Ah, das ist eine gute Frage.
Also was ich scheiße finde ist, dass der das so auf den Sack kriegt.
Das hat aber nichts mit der Overwatch League an sich zu tun.
Ansonsten, es gibt ein paar Sachen, die ich doof finde an der Overwatch League.
Das eine Mal ist, dass ich das Observing nicht sonderlich toll finde.
Ich meine, was bringt es mir, wenn ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
einen Winston in der Ecke stehen sehe,
während draußen die Tracer drei Gegner wegpascht.
Das Observing ist ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Dann, dass mein Lieblingscaster nicht dabei ist,
obwohl er eigentlich so der Overwatch-Caster schlechthin war am Anfang
und eigentlich die ganze Zeit jetzt bis zur Overwatch League.
Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen, ist das Ganze gut gemacht.
Ich habe Schlimmeres befürchtet, was die Produktion angeht,
nachdem sie sich ja da am Anfang überhaupt nicht mit Ruhm beklackert haben.
Ansonsten kann es nichts sagen.
So, und von den Spielen her finde ich,
es gibt viel zu viele einseitige Spiele in der Overwatch League.
3-0, 4-0.
Das ist nicht sonderlich spannend.
Aber es gibt auch geile Sachen.
Also an sich kannst du eigentlich nichts Großartiges, Negatives sagen.
Das funktioniert.
Ich bin halt, wie gesagt, außer das, was ich gesagt habe,
ich bin auch immer noch kein Fan von diesem ganzen Städtekonzept.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das auf Dauer als so toll erweist,
weil ich meine, so für die Nachwuchsszene ist jetzt ja dann nicht so viel zu holen.
Du kannst aus der Overwatch League nicht absteigen.
Du kannst in die Overwatch League nicht aufsteigen.
Welchen Anreiz hat dann zum Beispiel eine Organisation oder ein Sponsor,
ein Team zu sponsoren, was nicht in der Overwatch League ist?
Und was vielleicht ein Newcomer-Team ist, das richtig gut ist,
wenn er weiß, dass die Spieler zwangsläufig nicht unter seiner Flagge weiter spielen können,
wenn sie sich verbessern.
Also was hat da einer für ein Interesse dran, ein Team zu fördern?
Ja, der Map Pool ist auch ziemlich klein, das stimmt.
Weil ich weiß gar nicht, habe ich mich, habe ich mich geil darüber informiert,
ob der Map Pool wirklich so klein ist oder ob die einfach immer die gleichen Maps wählen.
2CP ist immer noch ein scheiß Modus, was man auch in der Overwatch League schön sieht,
wo du bestraft wirst für gutes Defenden teilweise.
Also zumindest überhaupt nicht mein Fall.
Ja, soviel zum Thema Overwatch League.
Also an sich finde ich es gut.
Ich gucke es gerne leider halt zu absoluten kacke EU-Zeiten,
also wirklich den beschissensten EU-Zeiten, die es überhaupt gibt.
Ich gucke manchmal morgens auf den Weg zur Arbeit noch Overwatch League.
Dann steige ich am Südbahnhof aus morgens und laufe so 25 Minuten, 30 Minuten.
Und je nachdem, wie knapp die Matches waren, läuft dann auch Overwatch League.
Ich ziehe mir dann mein Headset auf, also mittlerweile so ein Bluetooth-Headset,
was übrigens echt geil ist.
Warum habe ich eigentlich...
Stimmt das hier, dass ich eine... Ach, das ist Swap oder sowas, ne?
Angeblich habe ich den Load auf 100%, das ist ein bisschen viel, ne?
Oh, Visual Studio Code geht da ab im Hintergrund, was denn da los?
Warum hängt denn das auf 125%, CPU?
JavaScript, null, null, JavaScript.
Machen wir es mal zu, zack.
Warum brauchen wir so viel CPU-Last? Hallo? Das ist... Das macht doch nix.
Tja, so ist das halt mit Elektron-Java-Script-Kacke.
Kann man einfach im Hintergrund nicht auflassen, wenn man nicht will, dass es irgendwann 20 GB RAM belegt.
Hardtop, oh ja, stimmt, haha. Ganz vergessen, das muss natürlich auch noch drauf.
Ich glaube, das ist sogar so eingestellt, dass mittlerweile... Nee.
Ist nicht automatisch verlinkt. Ja, aber Hardtop, das muss sein, das stimmt. Das stimmt natürlich.
Wie findest du eigentlich progressive Web-Apps?
Das scheint mir irgendein neues Buzzword zu sein, das kenne ich noch nicht.
Was sind progressive Web-Apps?
Ich meine, JavaScript-Leuten gehen die Buzzwords nie aus, das ist mir schon klar.
Und wenn du heute eine Sache bei JavaScript kannst, weißt du, morgen gibt es 20 neue Libraries,
die dann das bisschen anders machen und das, was du kannst, ist nicht mehr angesagt.
Aber was sind progressive Web-Apps?
Ey, das wusste ich jetzt mal, was ist denn das hier?
Progressive Web-Apps. Wenn ich den ersten Satz schon lese.
Progressive Web-Apps are user experiences.
Na, da stehen sie auf ihrer Google-Konferenz wieder rum und finden sich geil, ne?
Okay, ich wollte erst sagen, es ist Go, aber es ist anscheinend nicht Go.
Das ist Jason.
Das erzählen sie doch alle immer. Zuverlässig, schnell und ja, engaging.
Die Leute stehen drauf und sind halt engaged. Interagieren damit.
Und was genau ist das jetzt? Ich finde solche Seiten immer geil.
Die machst du auf und anstatt dass da oben da steht, was genau ist es, steht erst mal da, was es geiles macht.
Die sich wie eine App anfühlt, aber das ist ja nichts Neues im Prinzip.
UWP Master Race, ne? Nee, ganz bestimmt nicht. Ich hatte ja vor, mein Screenshot-Tool mit UWP zu machen, habe ich ja schon mal erzählt, ne? Im letzten Stream.
Aber leider, leider kann man mit UWP genau diese Funktionen, die ich verwenden möchte, dass die Screenshot-App eben nämlich zur Screenshot-App wird, jetzt fange ich auch schon mit App an,
dass das Screenshot-Tool zum Screenshot-Tool wird nicht machen, weil man kann mit UWP keine Screenshots machen.
Wer hätte ja auch bei Microsoft denken können, dass Leute vielleicht mit ihren Programmen Screenshots machen wollen?
Also da kann man bei Microsoft nicht drauf kommen. Screenshots sind ja nur wirklich jetzt keine alltägliche Sache im Jahr 2018.
Da kann man schon mal sagen, das braucht man nicht.
Was ist denn das? Invisible Darkness. Ach, ist das der Hacker? Ja, ja, das kenne ich, das kenne ich. Das kenne ich, das ist lustig.
Das ist so was nach dem Motto, wenn der Chef reinkommt, man muss Aktivität faken. Ich zeige euch mal ein Video von, ich will das nicht installieren.
Das sieht dann so aus, wenn man es ausführt. Dann macht es halt irgendwelche Programme auf und macht irgendwas.
Also da tippt halt keiner. Das ist so Aktivität faken. Wenn es nach was aussehen soll, startet man das einfach und dann macht es halt Dinge.
Welche Distribution? Das ist Manjaro Linux.
Ja, also das ist halb.
Welche Linux-Distribution würdest du zu einem ersten Mal reinkommen?
Hast du irgendwelche Erfahrungen mit Unix oder BSD?
Wenn du komplett neu bist, würde ich sagen, probier Ubuntu zuerst oder Fedora für Desktop.
Oh, der arbeitet aber schnell.
Benutzt du das Screenshot-Tool eigentlich? Das ist ja noch nicht fertig. Das muss man ja auch noch fertig machen.
Ich habe jetzt letzten noch ein bisschen rumgebastelt. Ich habe das noch ein bisschen erweitert, dass ich jetzt ordentlich markieren kann und mir speichern kann, welchen Bereich ich vom Screenshot markiert habe.
Dass es auch alles mitresized wird und sowas. Dass es eine Default-Image anzeigt, wenn noch nichts geladen ist und sowas in der Richtung.
Das mache ich aber alles dann noch mal zusammen in irgendeinem Stream noch mal neu. Also halt so, wie ich es jetzt gebaut habe, machen wir das dann noch mal zusammen im Stream.
Ja, das kenne ich. Default SSR, das kenne ich.
Aber ich habe immer noch nicht verstanden, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Was? Was genau? Warum? Was ist das jetzt? Checklist.
Ok. Your First Progressive Web App. Ok, was genau? Zeig mal Code Beispiele. Was? Nein. Sample Code. Ok.
Jo, das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Your First Progressive Unzip. Was? TST, was zum Teufel ist das?
Ich habe ein Stuff, kein Zip-Zeugs installiert. Mini-Zip. Unzip.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Jo. Ach, ich hab's. Unzip. So, jetzt gucken wir uns das mal an. Was ist denn das?
Ok. Die Google Logik ist natürlich schon mal, dass das Ganze bei Step 2 anfängt. Step 1 gibt es nicht.
Step 1 ist absolut overrated, outdated. Step 2 activated. So, was ist das jetzt?
Ich check's nicht. Was ist das? Das ist doch wieder einfach nur irgendwie Bullshit-Buzzword-Gedöns.
Die App einfach im Browser laufen lassen. Ja, aber das geht doch jetzt schon. Ich verstehe nicht, was da dran neu ist,
weil du kannst ja jetzt auch schon einfach eine Webseite bauen, die auf dem mobilen Gerät halt nicht so aussieht,
sondern hier irgendwie so dieses komisches Hamburger Menü hat und so, wenn man das will. Also, oder halt mit Elektron, ja.
Oder du kannst ja mittlerweile, du kannst ja auch mit diesem Xamarin Zeug mobile Apps machen und so,
die auf allen devices laufen. Was auch immer. Da haben sie sich wieder irgendwas ausgedacht,
was anscheinend jetzt der neueste, geilste Shit ist. Und je nachdem juckt es dann wahrscheinlich in einem halben Jahr
oder nach einer Weile wieder kein. Es sei denn, es kommt gut an. Aber ich meine öfters mal neue Sachen.
Wir gucken mal, was die, was die IT-Buzzwords 2018 sind. Gucken. Also, was ich mitgekriegt habe,
was angesagt ist, sind, also DevOps ist immer noch angesagt, wobei DevOps ist schon mittlerweile Standard.
Das juckt schon gar kein mehr. Aktuell ist Full-Stack-Developer angesagt. Das ist auch voll im Trend, ja.
Aber das ist auch schon wieder ein bisschen aus, out. So. Jetzt ist die Frage, was ist jetzt angesagt im Jahr 2018?
Warum sind die alle so gut drauf immer in diesen Bildern mit TF? Und was hat das mit IT-Buzzwords zu tun?
Versteh ich nicht. Was gibt's denn da so Neues? Technology-Buzzwords 2018. EOD. EOD muss natürlich auch sein, ja.
Na, Mobile First ist doch nicht mehr. Das ist doch schon outdated, komplett. Das hat der neue Microsoft-Chef 2015 oder so erzählt.
Microservices ist auch out. Das sagt doch keiner. Dark Data. Das hab ich doch nicht gehört. Dark Data. TriHard 7. Dark Data. Keine Ahnung. Was ist das?
Nein. Geh weg. Piss dich alle. Okay. Erklären die uns auch, was das ist? Was? Digital Detox. Aha.
Okay. Was ist Dark Data? Ich will das jetzt wissen. Dark Data. Okay. Aha. Dark Data ist also quasi Müll, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also sprich, der Müll, der sich's über die Jahre so ansammelt, ist Dark Data. Das ist Dark Data. Okay.
Okay, da hat mal einer wieder irgendwas erfunden, um ne Sache, die es eigentlich schon immer gibt und schon lange gibt und schon einfach wieder mal ein neues Wort drauf zu hauen.
Was haben die da dazu zu schreiben? Development Trends. Oh, was gibt's denn da? IOT. Überall IOT. Hier wieder IOT. Cloud-based Apps. Das ist jetzt gar nichts Neues.
IOT. Achso, bring your own device. Ich hab jetzt gedacht, das ist Mobile Payment. Okay, das ist auch neuer Trend. Wusste ich noch gar nicht.
Mein Gott, diese Artikel, die sind immer so, die sind genauso schlimm wie die ganzen Buzzwords dabei. Ja, das ist tatsächlich ne Sache, die ist wichtig. Die ist wirklich wichtig.
Und da tut sich viel. Ich will euch nicht folgen, aber Dark Data finde ich gut. Dark Data hat was.
Aber der Rest von IOT beeindruckt mich jetzt nicht so sehr an Buzzwords. Das ist nicht so. Das ist ein Artikel, der einfach von dem anderen abgeschrieben ist oder der andere Artikel von dem.
Das ist ja langweilig.
Okay, die CPU-Auslastung update. Geht ab hier. Ich hab einfach mal 10% CPU-Auslastung, weil hier ein Ascii-Quarium läuft und ein Hardtop.
Ah, die CPU-Auslastung verursacht der, wie heißt es eigentlich richtig, Composite Manager. Nee, wie heißt denn das richtig? Also das Ding, was für Transparenz und so zuständig ist, auch voll so überhaupt keine Transparenz macht.
Aber ich brauch einfach mal 48% CPU-Auslastung. Warum auch immer für nix.
So, nee, ich mach heute nichts mehr, Leute. Ist jetzt fast 23 Uhr. Ich war schon am Anfang des Streams mega im Arsch. Jetzt bin ich noch mehr im Arsch.
Ja man, jetzt Schluss. Vielleicht spielen wir morgen Overwatch. Gucken. Oh, ein E-Ax-Fragen. Eigentlich will ich kein Overwatch mehr spielen, weil ich reg mich jedes Mal auf und jedes Mal, wenn es mir Spaß macht und ich spiele das wieder intensiver, reg ich mich umso mehr auf.
Eigentlich hab ich mir vorgenommen, kein Overwatch mehr zu spielen, bis es da irgendwie funktionierendes, motivierendes Rankingsystem gibt. Vor allem eins, das auch Teamplay und Gruppensachen fördert.
Ich glaube, ich spiele morgen kein Overwatch. Ich muss jetzt erstmal YouTube-Zeugs machen. Wichtig. Hab euch ja vorhin die Statistik gezeigt.
BDO. Ja, ich würde ja mit dem Fabian BDO spielen, aber da ist ja irgendwie ganze Zeit nur AFK in BDO am rumstehen.
Wie BDO läuft, ich lock mich einfach nur ein und hole Daily-Rewards ab. Fertig. Muss ich übrigens noch machen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Gut, dass wir mal drüber gesprochen haben. Da mach ich das jetzt nämlich mal. Daily-Rewards abgreifen.
Naja, das war heute ein sehr unproduktiver Stream, aber wir haben Emojis in der Leiste jetzt.
Okay Leute, machts gut. Bis dann, see you.